Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
Okay, and welcome.
This is gonna be my very first time playing ARC ever.
And like, honestly, I actually don't know how the ping is
gonna be like.
Because, you know, it's like, you might need to get
something to help you boost your ping to the server, maybe.
And I was like, oh, it'll be fine.
We'll figure this out live.
I'm sure I might have should have you know tested it out
tested out the server ping before you know before the stream
but like I don't know I just believed if I believe enough
it'll be okay as long as we keep believing it will be okay
yes yes welcome um I've never played arc before guys never
in my life The reason why we're playing our very late at
night is because this is the Billy Billy VTuber server that
Hero invited me to.
And, you know, a majority of the people will be playing, you
know, at their hours.
Because I was asking Hero, I was like, oh, like what time do
usually people get on?
And they're like, she was like, oh, like 4 a.m.
my time.
so I was like maybe not I'm just thinking I'm gonna this is
a compromise I was like you know maybe not 4 a.m.
I don't really want to I don't really want to play arc at 4
in the morning so 11 p.m.
would be the best bet thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you now placing bets on how she's going to pronounce
Waverne.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, I have zero knowledge of this game.
And they never played ARC before, so this is going to be
interesting.
I'm ready for all the backseaters to like yell at me because
I have no clue what the fuck to do in ARC.
I have idea what to do um and oh yeah also a little funny
update so like you know how like yesterday i was like you
know what let's just play every copy like let's just play
copyright songs yesterday well not cop okay not technically
yes like jazz like i mean it's still jazz it's not like
clicking uh it's not like disney composed a jazz song it was
like a cover song of jazz But anyway, I got, I'm sharing
revenue with Disney, Nintendo, and Ghibli.
Look, look, if I was gonna get copyright-striked, if I was
gonna get, like, copyright-striked, I want all the companies
fight each other for my $5.
Like, I don't want one single company to have that entire
$5.
I want all of those companies fight for it.
So, like, in the end, you know, they all get...
like 50 cents or some shit like I don't care now all three
of them will have to
share fight fight fight that's what I said that's what I was
like look if I'm gonna be playing like jazz songs from if
I'm gonna get striked I might as well just commit you know i
might as well fully commit and just play all the jazz music
from all the companies like i i was gonna get i was gonna
have to share revenue anyway chat like like i was gonna get
striked anyway might as well share the wealth with all the
other companies okay bring the music down don't worry i got
you uh
all right it's time to make our our character what do we
wait what was the default okay i could be like it's like i
never went outside i never went outside and i got chucked
into this world that's gonna be that's gonna be where wait
are we all like oh shit holy shit okay Are we all, like,
semi-bald?
Is that it?
Pill has a corpse?
I mean, we got the eyes, correct?
Okay, head size.
Oh my god.
Okay.
And then...
What's the...
Oh my god!
What a fucking Chad!
Okay.
Yes.
Wait, I can literally make a Chad?
Holy shit!
Wait a minute.
Wait, this changes everything.
This changes everything.
Oh my god.
Is she mewing?
I finally did it.
Wait, okay.
I want to be like semi mewing.
Like I'm still in the process of getting better at mewing.
Okay, what's the lower face with?
Alright, I need you guys to help me like read too because
like people are typing in Chinese and I can't read.
So if they're like saying something that I should know let
me know.
Oh, oh, wait.
I don't know.
Okay.
Actually, I want that to be medium because I actually really
like, okay, we'll have a smaller head because, uh, no,
actually, you know, semi-small head and do I have to have
abs?
Cause like, I just literally just went outside right now.
I went outside and I got chucked into the, apparently this
game has lore.
Apparently there's an animated showed that like appeared out
of nowhere and it was like a star studded cast and then
everyone forgot about it because it literally just came out
of nowhere like there was no advertising oh my god there was
like no advertising whatsoever but like it was like the
fucking the most star studded cast ever um yeah but like I
heard that this game has like intense lore Okay, and then we
don't have to worry about any of that.
Wait, hips.
Okay, yes.
And then I actually sort of want, like, nice thighs.
Ooh, no.
Short king.
Short queen.
Ooh, yes.
Okay, and then we're like chicken legs.
There you go.
Yeah, I'm just like you guys, dragoons.
I'm just like all of you.
Antonio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for sharing your hard-earned money with those poor
multi-million dollar companies.
Please truly say Thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Red dog, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you I can't believe it's been three months since your
return My brain right in mind Back then was imagining you do
Hey Hachi walk up from Tekken 7 Coming out of the red
volcanic smoke Completely stand still Thank you, super chat
Thank you, thank you Um Alright, I think that's perfect
Alright Real Email Dose key.
There you go.
Great new survivor.
I think that's...
I think that's good.
If I'm too...
Like...
If I'm too short, then like people will have a harder time
hitting me.
Because like they'll aim for head level, but like I'm so
short that like my head level isn't head level.
So...
Ah!
Flashbang!
Alright, let's see how bad the ping is.
Alright.
To like halfway for Hunter never paid attention to music.
Okay.
let's make sure you're cold you should find some warm soon
oh okay is there like free inventory wait what's this what
the fuck are is this free stuff oh it's free stuff right did
it give me free stuff okay let me like fix the sound real
quick okay music oh my god i get free stuff They're
everybody's so nice.
How do...
Where's the fucking sense?
Where's the sense?
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
No camera shake, please.
Uh, we're gonna turn that down.
Fucking hate camera shake.
I'm sorry.
I think camera shake is dumb.
I don't care about immersiveness.
All right.
Here you go.
Wait, what can I take?
Okay, I'm gonna take...
Wait, what is my...
Is this my inventory?
Wait, I already have it.
armor um how do i open my inventory is this okay how do i oh
my god i'm already overwhelmed
wait why can't i put it on did i put it on or did i put it
away no i put it away what did i put This is it.
I.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm beautiful.
Okay.
Equipped.
Wait, I have so many things.
That's crazy.
I have so many things.
Put this in my hand.
Is there a tutorial for...
Wait, I leveled up from existing!
God, I wish that was, like, real life.
wait what should i um what what should i get i just level it
up just for existing i love it uh i hope you have some
knowledge of herbivores and carnivores if it looks
threatening it probably is just beware even if they're small
acts thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right what do i get hp okay whoa oh my gosh i feel like i
should get a Pickaxe?
Right?
I don't want to make a pickaxe.
That's what I want to make.
Alright guys.
Wait, there's stuff over there.
Alright guys, here we go.
There's so much.
Wait, there's colors over there.
Do you think that's a good color?
Do you think that's friendly?
Hello?
Wait, there's so many colors around the world.
Wait, are those friendly colors?
Are those...
Whoa!
That must be friendly.
Oh!
That's not fair!
I was following...
I was just...
I was just following the colors!
No!
All my items!
I had so many items!
I was rich!
Oh, I still have it.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God I still have it.
Hey, guys.
I still got it.
Nice.
Okay, everything's fine.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I can have costumes and dodo birds.
How do I get the dodo bird?
Guys, I'm okay, guys.
All right.
Everything is okay.
We're off to a good start.
We're off to a good start, guys.
I keep following the...
Guys, guys, following the colors is very dangerous.
I'm like those flies that follow the bright colors.
You know, like those flies that follow the zapper?
And you're like, ooh, follow the zapper.
You're tired.
Stop moving.
Ooh, pretty colors.
Wait, is this where I died?
Okay, we can easily fix this.
Wait, how the fuck?
Oh!
Wait, Santa Claus?
What is that?
It's okay.
We're back.
That's not bad.
Look, it's through Santa.
I got distracted by Santa.
It's okay, round three.
I got distracted by Santa!
I heard a ho ho ho ho!
Okay, let's turn up the gamma.
Alright, I know a lot of you guys kept yelling at me to turn
up.
Wait, how do you turn up gamma?
Where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
There's a gamma?
Can you actually...
Are you guys fucking with me?
Yeah, tap.
I don't know if you guys are fucking with me, or if there's
actual, like, it's oddly under key bindings.
It is?
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, there you go.
Do we do gamma 1 or gamma 2?
Tab type gamma.
And type, uh, should this be 3 or 4?
Oh, wait, you guys can't see.
Is it gamma 1 or 2, guys?
it?
One or two?
Yes.
Thanks.
That's very helpful.
Okay, I'm gonna put three.
Alright.
That should be fine.
Okay.
Good.
Alright.
Did it fix anything?
Did it fix anything, guys?
Because I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh, we bring down the music a little bit more.
I'll bring it down a little bit more.
Yeah, I can't.
Oh, I didn't hit apply.
Sorry, I'm a little special.
There we go.
That should work.
Did it fix anything?
I should have asked Hiro to, like, help me explore note.
Are you the one I've been waiting for?
Oh, my God, lore!
You might be.
so it's been so many cycles since i was her do i even still
remember hope i wasn't sure you'd ever turn up that's me i'm
here to save your life don't mind about all the other dead
doki's behind me but i'm here you can count on me i'm very
reliable you have to reach me everything depends on My
survival?
Whoa, bet on the wrong person.
Dokey number one and two.
Did not do so well in this world.
Bad news.
Me?
Really?
I'm the only one?
Oh shit.
Oh, lore.
Okay.
Cool.
Where's my mouse?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
I got lore.
Oh, level up is available?
Okay.
I can level up now.
Alright, what do we get, guys?
Is it still health?
Is it...
Do we really need gamma 4?
Do we really need...
Wait?
Oh, okay.
Okay, wait.
Yay!
Alright.
I leveled up.
I'm slowly learning.
Okay, let me...
Apparently, people keep yelling at me to do Gamma 4.
Gamma 4.
Whoa!
Guys!
This is a whole different game.
Oh my god!
Whoa!
what the fuck this is a different game now we we can see now
holy shit is this where i died like three times or two times
oh yeah that's definitely where i died two times the
two-time champion all right i don't know where to go there's
apparently like 10 people on the server right now all right
where do we oh look look at all the dinosaurs that's a
that's a herbivore right there i know my dinosaurs that's a
triceratops and then that's a brontosaurus you think i live
dokey number three is gonna find out oh dokey number three
is okay yay oh dokey number three is gonna figure out how to
parkour this
See?
Doki number three is learning from one and two.
This is bad.
All right, here.
All right.
There's no way I die from this.
Doki number three.
four coming in hot.
Don't worry.
Doki number four has learned from all the mistakes from all
the other dokees.
All the other dokees they've learned.
They have learned.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
There's gonna be so much armor.
I don't know where to go.
Where's the map?
Oh, there's the map.
What the fuck?
That's just it.
That's just all the map.
That's me.
Right there.
All right.
Is there like any way I can go?
I feel like I'm like locked in here.
Like I feel like I'm actually locked in here.
All right.
I can't reach nowhere else.
Let's see.
I think they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
There has to be like somewhere I can go.
How do I leave?
punch a tree but i don't want to live here i want to find
like a nice place to live jesus christ those are all my dead
bodies like there's too many
it's okay it's fine we'll figure this out live oh
dragonflies wait can i eat these can i eat you guys wait
wait they hurt Oh my god, there's so many!
Oh, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
There is, like, a fucking clan!
Yeah.
Decomposes.
Bluff full of 170?
How the fuck do I farm you?
Oh, I got it.
I got raw meat.
From fucking insects?
Hey, guys, I got some raw meat.
Wait, where are the other ones that I killed?
I swear.
There's, like, more.
It's okay, guys, I'm learning.
I got raw meat now.
I did it.
Yay!
Oh, I should punch some trees.
Oh, that's a lot.
What the fuck?
I'm strong as hell.
Oh my god.
Did you say see that?
I'm so fucking strong.
Those looks like herbivores.
Wait, all of them look like herbivores, except for that one
raptor.
I can harvest a bush for berries, but I'm not hungry yet, I
think.
How do I get water, though?
I wonder.
Wait, that doesn't look like a herb.
Why are they like the herb?
No, they're all herbivores.
Yeah.
They're all herbivores.
They're all friends.
Guys.
Watch this, guys.
Oh!
Wait, this tree is still alive.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
Yay!
Bro, I'm so fucking strong.
Is that poop?
We might need this.
Wait, somebody dropped it.
Thank you, Cancer.
I can't believe they would waste, like, good fertilizer like
that.
Poop is good fertilizer.
Are you friend-shaped?
It's fine.
He doesn't know how to fly.
Get over here.
You don't know how to get over here.
Get over here!
I'm hungry!
Diet is canon and Lord, you learn from your past life
mistakes.
It's so funny.
Doki 5 is canon.
Victory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
It ran away.
Why would it run away from me?
I've been nothing but kind.
Ooh, there's so many dinos.
Okay, let me look at my inventory because I can upgrade
again.
What should I get, guys?
Wait, I'm slowly starving.
Cook my meat?
But how do I make fire?
I haven't learned yet.
What do I get, guys?
Wait?
Okay, I'll do more weight.
No, because then I'll get sick.
This is, like, good fertilizer.
I'm not going to waste good fertilizer, chat.
That's crazy.
Guys, where does my mouse go?
I saw there it is I was like where the fuck did I wait I
have so many points of oh my god leveled up so much wait
speed stamp HP and wait okay stamina speed stamina there's
apparently like a lot of mods too for this game okay wait is
my stomach do I have issues Don't answer that Not speed But
people are seeing High level Because look Because I fucking
destroy the tree in one hit What do you mean?
Okay Why do I need oxygen Just fucking breathe Let's see A
little bit of melee damage Okay we have three more 200%?
You mean this?
Movement speed?
What about crafting?
Or fortitude?
What the fuck is fortitude?
Can we reach does matter now?
Oh, okay.
I'll upgrade my speed.
And then...
Um... Just breathe.
I don't understand.
I still want to make a...
Oh, I can make a stone hatchet.
Wait, I can make a gun?
Oh my god.
Guys, I can make a fucking gun all right just like power um
what else can i make let's see why don't really need clothes
i already have clothes oh i should get like a sleeping bag
and then oh a saddle i like saddles oh and a regular bed i
learned so many oh my god look at all these things that i
learned there's so much stuff i'm getting overwhelmed right
now all right let's find a house i want to be next somebody.
Would it be rude if I make my, if I make it next to
somebody's house?
Where did I poop?
Is that my poop?
Pick up?
Sure.
I mean, it's good.
It's fertilizer.
I'm not gonna waste good old fertilizer.
Okay.
Am I hungry yet?
Okay, we need to make like, how do I craft?
All right.
Oh my god, look at all this fertilizer.
Wait, somebody dropped this.
Wait, somebody was next to me.
see somebody dropped this they were next to me they dropped
all this good ass poop look at that okay uh how do i craft
chat how do i how do i craft oh my god you've been how did i
get poison bro i was just existing That's so fucked up!
Oh, oh!
It's just existing.
No!
That's not fair!
I was starting to learn!
I just wanted to exist!
That's not fair!
Doki number five is here I don't even know where Doki number
four went where did Doki number four go
I can't believe I died to fucking a bullshit I'm so sad
Doki number five where did Doki number four die Doki number
five has to figure this shit out.
Where the fuck did I die?
The drive-by.
I can't believe it.
Wait, Hiro's on.
You have made an enemy at the Super Save mega level bugs.
Doki is doomed.
Doki number four was doomed.
Doki number five still has a chance.
Wait, is this where I died?
This could be where I died.
There's so many dead bodies.
Wait, there's somebody else died to my right.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
Doki number five is gonna be okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's not like the other...
The others are not here.
To kill me.
Alright.
What the fuck?
How is there still bugs how are you fucking camping my body
oh my god he's literally camping my body bro that's so
fucked up that is so fucked up
it's not fair leave me alone i just want my lord welcome to
the army Guys, dokey number six can clutch this.
Guys, I hate this area.
I hate this spot.
Don't worry.
Dokey number six has figured stuff out.
Dokey number six has figured it all out, guys.
Guys, do not worry.
Okay, we're gonna get our shit back.
Just gonna look at the logs and it's just like a dokey dead
dead.
Doki has died.
Somebody made a fire.
Wait.
Who was here?
Somebody was just here and I missed them.
I can't believe it.
Somebody was just here and I actually missed them.
Okay.
Where did I die?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
There's my stuff.
Doki 20 is not as far as I thought.
Okay.
The bugs can't hit you.
that is so smart that's so smart okay there's no way the
bugs would be all the way here there's no fucking way right
oh oh oh oh oh no this is so fucked up are you fucking bro
he's actually camping me bro i'm so mad these Oh my god!
Bro, leave me alone!
Please, I just want my stuff!
Leave me alone!
Insect 3, dokey 0.
No!
I need...
Oh my god, the worst part!
like he's just slowly killing me he actually is just slowly
giving me up this is it jokie 7 has learned everything she
could learn to fucking beat arc you're not good at the whole
oh I'm sorry there's like a fucking level 300 bug fucking
camping my body like what the fuck do I do um my god okay
it's okay we'll be fine we'll be fine joki 7 has figured
things out joki 8 is in a death loop all right don't worry
we'll figure this out oh my god it's so bright now there's
no way it counts me again there's no way all right we're
gonna go around there he is There he fucking is!
He just flew above me like a little whore!
Okay, to be fair, all bugs are technically whores because,
like, they make a lot of babies and they also fuck a lot.
So, like, it's, like, scientifically accurate if you think
about it.
Because all they do when they are born is just they want to
bang and then when they want to bang and make babies.
So technically all insects are whores.
Oh my god Thank fucking god I got my shit back It's true The
moment they're like outside The moment they're like outside
the pupa stage All they want to do is bang So scientifically
all insects are horrors We will not listen to this slander
Holy shit, I cannot see.
Okay, I need a fucking gamma 3 or some shit.
This is way too bright for me.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Wait, is that friend?
That's a bear.
Wait.
Are you friend?
Hello.
Oh, my god, I'm getting flashbanged.
Wait, can I...
Can they be my pet?
Do you want to be...
Do you want to join me?
Why are you running away?
I want...
I want him to...
Check settings.
Oh, I can turn off Bloom.
Okay, guys, thank you.
Where's Bloom?
Motion blur.
Oh, light Bloom.
Yeah, fuck that.
that is terrible oh my god oh my god that's a lot better
okay i need a no oh okay it's fine it's fine it's fine we
can we'll be okay craft slingshot to knock out and tame a
dino wait how do you craft guys i still have not figured out
how to craft stuff wait there's somebody's box over here it
was like red i'm dehydrated fine water Oh, that's not
friend.
Oh, oh, oh, hey.
Who's that?
Hello?
They're
flying.
Wait, oh my god.
Wait.
I'm dying of thirst right now.
Do you have any water?
Oh my god, thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I died like seven times.
I don't know how to play this game.
There's water.
How do I...
Oh my god, I'm okay now.
Yeah, I died seven times.
Can I like steal your...
How do I get on?
Okay.
But, like, we're in, like, a tribe right now.
Oh, shit.
You want to come in?
You want to join our tribe?
Yeah, I want to join your tribe.
Will you take care of me?
Are you guys going to take care of me and feed me?
Please, I'm baby.
I need to be fed and watered.
Oh, my God.
It's so cute.
Can he die?
Yeah, that's an otter.
Oh!
Okay, how do I join your tribe?
Oh.
Hold- oh, okay.
Accept invitation.
Try Baka?
Try with five?
Yeah!
Don't worry.
It's okay.
We're not buck up.
Wait, oh my god, your boobs.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Hey.
I don't know why she's so tiny.
Oh my god.
She's so...
We're fucking...
I can't stop looking.
Oh my god!
For free?
Don't worry, here, I'll pay for it.
Here, this is my payment.
I'll give this to you.
Oh!
Vampire Dodo.
Oh, is that close?
Oh, for a swimsuit.
Yeah, you can drag it onto your clothes.
And you're like, look, it's like a skin.
Oh!
Okay.
Let's see.
You gotta hold you.
Wait.
How do I...
How do I put it on?
Drag it onto your current clothes.
What?
How do I put this on?
I can only drop it.
Oh, oh!
You drag it onto your current clothes.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm hot now.
Look at me.
Oh.
Am I hot?
Am I sexy?
Yeah, Natchan?
Oh, don't worry.
I can take it off for you, Natchan.
Don't worry.
We're heroes wise
I'll strip I'll strip for I'll strip for I get sick What the
hell I I can take it all off if I can have this mount.
And...
Wait!
You're like cutting in and out for me!
Wait, my audio?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why?
Is it like the server?
Like...
No, I...
Me.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you're like a robot.
I don't know why it's me.
I think you're...
Hey.
Wait, where's your...
Wait, show me your house.
I want to see your house.
You gotta join...
Hold E.
Hold E?
Oh, okay.
I thought I joined you guys.
Oh.
Wait, how come it won't let me?
Oh, there you go.
I got it.
Did I join you guys?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we're like...
Alright, it's easier to beat.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm part of your team.
Let's go, let's go.
Oh, pick me up, pick me up.
pick me up how do i how do i
okay okay oh
my god i can fly oh my god it's beautiful wait wait can you
guys help me kill a bug I want to Can you guys help me kill
a bug?
No, this bug killed me Like seven times This bug killed me
seven times, we gotta beat him up I have a team now Here,
here, here It's like right here, it's right here We gotta
find this bug, I wanna kill this bug Give me a sec Where is
he?
This bug has killed me Seven times, I need revenge Where is
This is all my bodies Where the fuck is that bug i'm so sad
where is he it was like level 300 where is he guys where's
the bug guys chat help me find the bug we need to kill him
and teach him a fucking lesson he's gone no okay he's gone
he despawned he despawned i'm so mad i finally could kill
him Alright, pick me up Pick me up pick me up Pick me up
pick me up pick me up Yeah, oh shit
Wait, I can't oh my god look at me go Oh, you're a natural
you're a natural natural am i like on push to talk or like
voice activation can you guys hear me okay i'm definitely on
push to talk right i was making sure chat if i was on push
to talk or voice activation because i didn't i did not look
at my oh i can zoom out oh they're getting me go guys i'm
like the eye candy for the tribe it gave me like a bikini
and now i know my place
it's okay don't feed guys they're gonna feed me and shelter
me guys
they're gonna feed me and shelter me and they gave me free
transportation oh my god the fucking flashbang you're not
gonna drop me guys Oh, what is that?
Is that horse?
Wait, is that... Whose house is that?
Is that your house?
The one over there?
No, no, no.
It's over here.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is that...
Is that the house?
Wait, what the fuck?
This looks like a place where we can like oh, it's a store
at all the pets and stuff Yeah, we can just do stuff like
inside there's like stuff Oh Oh my god, there's so many pets
can they die
Wait, if I actually stab them they'll die Yeah, they'll get
hurt Oh, okay, okay, I think you should heal your otter I
stabbed your otter earlier on accident oh my god there's so
many
oh my god there's an owl there's so many tech the what is it
like a tech version of the t-rex oh how what level is it 300
oh we can kill him I believe in us.
All right, we can do it.
Oh my god, who's this guy?
Who's Della?
Yeah, she's a V2 boy.
She sings a lot.
Oh!
She should do a concert for us.
Oh my god, do you guys farm these animals for poop?
This is Della.
I think she's farming poop.
Yeah, I was gonna say, are you farming them for poop?
poop oh my god oh my god guys i have a house now guys i have
a house and i didn't have to work for it i love it here
oh my god i want my
own i want my own mount wait i oh yeah i had to make a bed
okay guys all right i need to get a bed wait i'm gonna die
of thirst i just realized i am so thirsty uh where's the
water oh there it is consume all right not thirsty anymore
let's go i'm a squatter i'm not a squatter i provide like
entertainment Guys, it gave me a bikini.
I'm trying to thirst.
Yeah, yeah, I'm really...
Yeah, I need water, yeah.
Also, they...
Oh, my God.
Level 300?
Who the fuck caught that?
Oh, yeah, I want to catch, like, a flying thing, too.
Oh, food.
Yeah, not...
I don't need food too.
I'm starving, apparently.
Yeah, I'm hungry.
Oh, okay.
Do I just swim and then I drink water?
Oh, nice.
I'm learning.
Oh.
How do I...
Oh my god, I'm glitching out!
I'm here!
I'm okay!
All right.
Wait, are you dying?
Oh!
She's bleeding!
What the fuck?
Where's the food?
is feed me feed me i'm baby oh nice hey to the beach oh my
god our beach episode you start yeah we're having our beach
episode right now what the fuck yeah did you Put food in
inventory to tame.
Oh, I didn't give it food
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I put food in this inventory
Is it taming?
Oh, it needs berries Do I have berries?
Oh Okay
Yeah, yeah Okay, and then they'll like eventually become my
friend Yeah, so it's like
Like don't want to hit it.
Oh, oops.
I'm stuck Guys I'm stuck
I'm stuck!
No!
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Is he... you want to be friend?
Oh, 63%!
Okay.
Yay!
Oh my god, wait, you can make babies with them!
Because, right?
Female.
Oh!
Do you guys have the female?
Can my male...
Can my male guy...
Fang your female and make...
I don't have a female.
I don't have a male.
Okay.
63%.
Hello.
This is the normal one.
You don't have the...
Estimate.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I'm learning.
Oh, I see.
I have it, Dragoon!
Oh my god, look guys.
It's you, Dragoons.
That's you!
No, no, I'm sorry!
Oh, he's flying away!
Why is he flying away?
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry Oh saddle Equip saddle to ride Do I have a
saddle Do I Oh do you guys have a saddle?
Yeah
Oh okay All right Uh How's it Where's the saddle?
Is this one?
What the fuck is it called?
Okay Where's the color dragon where you guys color you guys
are yeah okay yeah i'm not i'm only level 17.
i'm just baby all right dragon come on dragon get over here
come on that's right
what it was an accident guys i didn't stab you guys it was a
dream i gave you guys a pet i pet you guys i like give you a
little pet oh my god i would never chat you're literally the
first thing i tamed i'll give you guys a little head pad
that red was just berries Yeah, it's caught.
I gave you guys like, you know, like hazing.
I like...
You know, I hazed you guys.
We'll take you to...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
You take her.
Natchen.
Natchen, grip me.
Pick me up.
Yay!
Where's my pet?
Where's my dragoons?
Wait, dragoons, why aren't you following me?
Dragoons, why aren't you following me?
It's safe!
Where's... we're gonna go to a new home, guys.
I...
Can she, like, accidentally drop me?
Oh my god, look at all these things.
other dragoons over there where's Hiro wait where's Hiro
Hiro Hiro where are you Nachon's lost yeah I was like I
didn't even know where you were
Wait, so you guys have two homes?
You guys have two houses?
Oh, we just...
How do I say...
That's like HQ.
Basically, we can use one of those there.
Oh, oh my god.
Is that the real house?
On the left?
Is that the real...
Oh, wait.
Can we...
Can we invade it?
Did you want to see?
Yeah, holy shit, why can't our house...
Are they here?
Oh my god.
Hello.
I can speak a little English.
Oh, you have a straw bag.
Nice.
I like it.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
They gave me a bikini.
So now they take care of me now.
Oh.
Can I...
Your house is beautiful.
Can I join your tribe?
Yeah, yeah, can I...
But they have guns!
Hiro!
Where's your gun, Hiro?
Okay,
okay.
They have gun!
I think they have gun, but they doesn't shoot it.
Oh, sorry.
It's okay.
I was joking here.
I would never leave your tribe.
It was joke.
I can't give you too much thing, but I can give you few.
Thank you!
Oh my god, thank you!
Don't be hungry.
Oh, thank you for taking care of me.
Don't worry, I'll dance for you.
for you.
Don't worry.
Here, you want to see the back?
Thank you.
I'll show you something.
Okay.
Come here.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Guys, their house is so much better.
No shame.
What the fuck?
Oh my guys.
That's beautiful.
she she will she will burn a baby after two two really can i
keep the baby baby oh just wait two minutes okay oh wait can
i watch it can i watch it yeah yeah of course oh my god they
gave me they gave me a hundred fucking me hero would never
you can you can join my group first and try to little monkey
oh my god where's the baby oh yeah like hold yeah yeah join
my team and then and then take the baby when you want to
change you just click it oh i see yeah don't mind yeah quit
that you want to join others it's fine But now you join me,
Groove, you can like try to like...
Oh my god!
Oh!
That is so cool!
You join my Groove and you can try it.
That's so cool!
Wait, I can?
Yeah, you...
Uh...
Press E, press E.
Oh, A, okay.
To...
Yeah, E to...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Look at me go!
Hero can never...
It's so fucking cool!
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Oh no, I'm stuck.
Oh, okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Go on, go on, run.
All right, nice.
Oh, parkour.
Oh, my God.
Look at me go!
Guys!
Guys, guys, I think I have a new family now.
Guys, I think I found a new family.
Wait, can I slap him?
Oh my god!
Get over here.
Monkey Supreme.
Bam.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Get out!
I'm having a good time.
try to press uh left button oh left button oh shit what the
fuck the key button c oh let's see oh my god i'm so strong
oh my god what doesn't hero have this
I will be just as strong.
Oh my god.
Let me just kill everything.
Holy shit.
Guys.
Oh, I did a thousand damage.
You want to go back to see the baby?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to see the baby.
Yeah.
To see the baby.
Guys.
This house is insane.
Oh my.
god this house is guys my new family oh my god look at the
baby oh
wait oh shit i'm sorry he's like he's like my baby now i'm
so sorry you can just you press t to let it uh stop t okay
it doesn't photo you okay you're not my baby anymore wait oh
oh oh how do i how do i how do i own it oh no what happened
what's going what happened
okay I'm not your mom leave leave I'm not your mom okay okay
oh there I see it uh stop how do I disown it
Oh, unclaimed!
There you go, I got it!
I got it.
He's not my- I disowned it.
He- he's not- He's not- He's not- You can eat?
Yeah.
He- He- He's- Wait, no, he is.
He's still my kid.
I don't want you.
Oh, I claimed it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm doing it now.
Okay, okay.
You're not my baby anymore.
I don't want you.
Okay.
Her tribe.
Okay, how do I join back to you?
Oh, okay, here you go.
That's a try.
It's a really nice game.
Yeah, thank you for letting me join your team.
Yeah, my first time.
It was so...
It's her first time, Pete.
Yeah.
Thank you again.
Thank you for letting me ride the gorilla.
Have a nice time.
You too.
Thank you.
All right, pick me up.
Your home is beautiful.
It is beautiful.
Wait, open!
Yeah, pick me up.
Oh, can you see the things looking here?
Could you come, come, come, please.
Okay.
Come, come, come.
it's it can like uh two people oh oh wait a minute oh my god
it's so beautiful oh my god guys i love being spoiled it's
really nice it's so nice oh my god thank you you will have
it one day I'll be just as rich as you guys.
Alright, bye-bye.
Alright, pick me up, pick me up.
I'm like a princess.
Did you miss?
Come on, Achen!
Yay!
Bye-bye!
See you!
Thank you again!
Bye-bye!
Oh my god, they're so nice!
One day...
Guys, are you guys as rich as them?
I thought we were going to your house Wait, but your dragon
is not there Wait, what?
I thought he followed me Wait, no, we can pick up the saddle
We can pick up the saddle at your place and then go back
We try to follow him.
Oh my god, everyone's so nice.
Everyone's so nice.
They're treating me so well.
Wait, can he...
No, wait!
That can happen?
That is what?
Oh,
they have to restart the server.
It's okay, we can get a new dragon.
We'll get new dragoons, guys.
It's fine.
And pretend that we never lost you.
You know, it's like how, like, people would...
Okay, it's so fucked up for me to say.
But, like, you know, there's, like, people that actually do
that.
Where they'll just buy the same pet.
And then you just rename it.
And then it's like they never died.
So, like, some people have done that.
Where they'll be like, my pet is, like, 80...
It's, like, the oldest living pet in the world.
Like 70 plus years old.
But then like the mom would just secretly replace it every
time.
And just name it the same thing.
So we're gonna do that.
What?
Whoa.
Are you okay?
Yeah?
What?
Don't say what?
So this is not really our home.
It's the temporary.
Oh It looks Look our members are not here.
It looks amazing
Wait this house It looks amazing I love it wait what is this
oh i'm too low oh yeah i'm too i'm too i'm too low level so
what about story yeah this is where everybody starts
basically uh-huh so natan just started she's not really high
level yet and and she took somebody else this is actually
somebody else made Whoa, what the fuck?
Oh yeah, there's somebody's...
Personal owner, Kudu Kudu.
This is beautiful.
Wait, and then I love this one.
Oh, she just put it as hers.
It was like somebody else's house.
Wait, this is not Chen's house.
It's very tiny.
Because she just started.
Wait, I should eat.
Give me a sec.
Let me eat.
I don't remember if you're like scared or take you somewhere
else.
Okay.
Basically, you stay here.
Okay, my house is bigger than that.
It's like, here in this area.
Oh, this is your house?
Yeah, I stayed up here just for a little bit.
I have nothing here yet.
What is this?
Oh, it's a grill!
Oh!
You can make food here.
You can have weapons with it.
Yeah, this is a free case here.
Oh my god.
One day I'll be just as rich.
Oh, I thought I fell down.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, is this like, uh, like a fountain?
Oh, I see.
I'm learning so much.
Uh, do you see?
Yeah?
Yeah, look, I've hidden all the pipes.
I should connect to them.
Oh, yeah, so it looks prettier.
Yeah, it looks pretty.
I'll see if you don't hide it in there.
Oh, I see.
And this is my breeding ground.
You're breeding ground!
Oh, my God.
Wait, what's the Santa thing?
Oh, it's an event.
What is it?
It's a Christmas event.
He'll drop.
friends from the sky and you can oh i see
oh my god what are you trying to breed oh yes what oh you're
gonna eat their babies that's so weird oh there's there's
food right here oh no that's poop that's poop never mind i
thought that's that was oh oh so you can eat the dodo's you
can make a chicken oh my god
oh i'm learning so much
I'll take you.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yay!
No, I'm okay.
Just a little bit.
A forbidden nugget.
You know what?
The reason why dodo birds are extinct is because apparently
they're really delicious.
That people just ate all of them.
Ooh, not that good.
Try the first house.
Like, everything's just weird right now.
Ooh.
Yeah, they're really stupid and but also delicious.
Apparently they're like they're like grade a like you know
how like there's like Kobe Kobe beef and stuff like that
Like it's basically like the chicken equivalent of like Kobe
beef
Actually, no they weren't how do you know you've never had a
fucking dodo bird Like how would you know they died before
you were born?
Kobe bird
You can't be like they weren't that delicious You literally
weren't even born when they were tied up How do I know
because there were books about it There were fucking books
written about it
And they said that like Oh no birds were delicious
Oh my god What the fuck is that yeah what is that oh my god
who what is that oh my god that's actually wait i feel like
i might die from cold i'm gonna freeze to death give me a
sec let me let me i'm only wearing a bikini
Oh my god, look at it.
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that?
I mean, oh I- no?
No, is this cute?
How is this cute?
And here, I don't know.
It looks fluffy.
What even is this?
You probably get this bag, buddy.
It's called ass bag.
Oh, my God.
Dude, this guy owns so many bugs.
This guy.
Look at this.
What is this?
What the fuck?
Is he sleeping in there?
What?
He's in the kingdom.
Oh, my God.
What?
They captured these people.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god!
He has prisoners?
I don't want to make him in.
This person that lives here is so crazy.
He's crazy?
He is a lie.
He sounds like really like a girl.
He's very like cute sounding.
But he's crazy.
He's crazy.
I mean, he's keeping prisoners.
Prisoner.
Yeah.
I think he actually jailed, you know, for that, like, uh,
Hey Lu Xiang.
Well, your mic is cutting in and out again.
Oh, can you hear me now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, the girl earlier that we met Hey Lu Xiang, uh, the one
that gave you the gorilla?
Yeah.
Like, or it's, like, like, handcuffed her.
So, I saw like- Say handcuffed her?
Yeah.
He handcuffed her as well.
like he's kind of crazy oh my god bro thank god he's not
online right now i think he's gonna i think he might like oh
he is oh my god i don't want him to put me in jail i'm
scared he has like actual prisoners
i'm scared
What the fuck?
What happened to the fucking moose?
How do they...
He has like a baby creature.
I gotta eat again.
I'm hungry again.
I'm always hungry.
Holy shit.
Guys, I don't want to go to jail.
Guys, I'm scared.
oh my god there's so many different kinds of animals though
bro this guy has like a fucking museum he has a museum did I
stole something I don't I don't even know if I did huh
what's going on wait Natchan is screaming yeah Natchan are
you okay what's going on what is that
Hello!
My guys, dodo birds are so high level.
Oh, yeah, I was like wondering what that was.
It's not really enemies, it's just...
It's just dodo birds, yeah.
He's not the... he's not that guy, right?
The prisoner guy?
He's just here.
He typed I don't think he has He's using mine right now Oh,
okay, okay I was like scared that it was him But Chris is on
though He is on?
I think he's somewhere He's somewhere He's somewhere Trying
to imprison more people The thing is He dropped like enemy
Like a dinosaur In a house Wait, he dropped stuff into your
house What?
Oh my god!
He's so scary!
Do you think he'll be my friend?
You think he'll be my friend?
Hello?
He wants to get back.
But I don't know if they will get back so I don't know if
they might start The server told that she doesn't know if
she wants to make eggs left.
She's trying to make eggs, I think.
Oh, yeah, that's fine.
We can restart server.
Wait a minute.
If we restart it, it's all the things we can do.
Go to like five minutes before it ends.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
We can restart it.
Apparently there's like a bug or something.
There's like a bug?
Somebody has like something which is like being a server.
Oh.
You can find it like earlier.
Because the tour is not fun, people can't enter the server.
Oh, that's weird.
That's weird.
Oh my god, this guy actually has a fucking zoo.
It's actually crazy.
Alright, we might have to...
We might have to...
We're gonna restart the server.
It's been a nice tour, though.
I'm enjoying looking around the art server.
I haven't learned much.
I didn't really learn how to play, but like, I'm having a
good time exploring.
We can go to, I think, one more person's house.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I can get you in trouble and like...
I will be in Junya's house.
It's been a fun tour.
I've been enjoying seeing everybody's houses.
Because the server's been up for like a week, I think.
and they let me see the gorilla i get to join somebody's
squad like i get to join somebody's like op fucking team
yeah did all this in like a week yeah wait is king kong that
is king kong actually that insane yet oh my guys my first
day and i already had a king kong baby but then i left i
disowned it because i'm not ready to be a parent
guys i'm so good at video i'm so good at video games on my
first day i got a king kong i get to ride a king kong you're
fully good Wait, Natchez, wait, where did Natchez go?
Natchez!
She's always lost.
I have no idea how she comes.
Natchez!
I went to get milk and left the, and left King Kong.
Wait, I think she's actually lost, lost.
Whoa, does somebody build this wait Hiro oh oh they
restarted the server guys I think the server got I don't
know if if Hiro DCs and I fucking fall I swear to god oh I
hope it's a restart
oh no oh oh what's going on Oh No Bro
I He
Oh my god
I was so scared No, I'm not dead
Holy shit, that was so scary.
Oh my god I was like, oh, no, she's carrying me.
I'm so fucked I'm so fucked No, no, if I don't guys, I can't
die if I I can't die guys There's no way, okay Apparently
the server is back up Alright, join Guys, it's okay I left
before I touched the ground So technically I'm still alive
Technically That'll be okay We're searching for I'm
searching for the session right now Wait, where is it?
Favorites uh i can't find the server is still not up yet it
says people are you notice i can enter now until you hit the
ground if i never if i never get back on i'll still be alive
oh they're not yet all right i'm gonna use the bathroom real
quick then i'll be right back guys i'll be right back
i'm back Apparently at the, let me say refresh.
Someone's at the re-add the server because they restarted
it.
Alright, let me re-add the server.
Okay, I need to find it again.
Give me a sec.
I'm learning.
I'm having fun, though.
Everybody's so friendly.
I like that.
I like it when people are nice.
Oh, it needs 10 minutes.
Never mind.
We still need 10 more minutes to restart.
start the server so we'll just chill a little bit but uh
it's pretty chill i really want to meet the criminal the
crazy guy oh i really i gave it back i didn't realize i took
the egg i was so used to just pressing e on stuff so but i
dropped the egg i dropped the egg before uh before uh before
I kept it.
But it's...
I want to meet the crazy guy that's been locking people up.
I know that Ikea's mic has been really fucking weird because
she was telling us how her PC sort of low-key dying.
And she was saying how...
I don't know if you guys heard it, but she was saying how
people were like dropped...
Like the crazy guy was dropping enemies into other people's
homes just to fuck with them.
And I was like, man, I'm a troll.
But that is like...
I don't know.
next level like i was just like oh my god that is next level
the fucked up like they actually dropped enemies onto other
people's homes i was like oh my god the one day you know was
like yeah he's crazy
i wanted and like he had like a cage of three different
people
he had like cages of three fucking people just sleeping
there next to like like I want to like apparently he's on
the server and I was saying like yeah like he's doing
something so I was just like oh okay like what is he he's a
little scary I'm gonna lie
they are the people no he did that to Hito's house He did
that to Hero's house.
That's why I was like, oh my god.
That's a whole next level.
What is he cooking?
And he was saying how like he was he had, he was saying like
he handcuffed several people.
Did I hear that?
They're like, yeah, like he handcuffed several kids.
He handcuffed the girl that gave me a gorilla.
Gave me King Kong.
Why did he do it though?
Because he's a fucking troll.
Because he's crazy.
Apparently.
what uh but yes i've been enjoying i can't believe the first
thing here one of the first things hero gave me was water
and a bikini and then at that point i knew my place look i
died seven times guys i fucking died seven times to a
goddamn insect i need this i need someone to take care of me
I Because I got I died to that fucking mosquito Seven
different times And I never got my revenge
Every single time It's okay It's alright guys But people are
so nice still that girl that that that the one with like all
the animals and like she let me join their tribe for like
five minutes so i would know what this feels like to be rich
in arc like
i get to feel the wealth in arc for like five to ten minutes
that was nice
and then she was gonna like she wanted to give me that
gorilla And I felt bad because I was like, no, it's okay.
Let me just, like, go for milk.
Go, like, no, no, don't, you don't need to give me the
gorilla.
It's okay.
Let me go out and, you know, go out and get some milk.
Their base, their base was not ugly.
I've seen an ugly base, but not a hero's base.
Hero's base was very pretty.
She gave me, she gave me prehistoric Mercedes.
Yeah!
She gave me a prehistoric Mercedes.
And I was like, Oh my god.
It was insane.
But then I felt like, you know, I was just like, Ooh, I
don't know, man.
Guys, I...
Oh.
Alright, let's see.
I'm going to see if the server is back up yet.
Sorry, we're waiting for the servers I think after I see the
house I'm going to try to tame another Dragoon Wait no, I'm
going to tame my first Dragoon because I never Tamed a
creature yet So I never tamed a creature yet So I want to
test it, try it out And then see And then we'll call it
there
Yeah, the server's still not up Yeah, the server's still not
up I'll be like, okay, let me know when it's, let me know.
I'm just chatting with my, with my dragoons.
Start with a daughter or something easy.
No, I want a pterodactyl.
I want a pterodactyl and call it a dragoon.
I've never tried it before.
They say, they said like 10 minutes.
Do not believe her lies.
what am i lying about i've never tamed anything in this game
before i never tamed anything aphelion thank you for the 10
gift of ships thank you thank you no it's peterodactyl it's
peterodactyl how would you know they don't they don't even
they're not even what what they're gonna fucking come back
from extinction to tell you like what they're actually
called like
You're dead!
They can't tell you what they're actually called.
The P is silent.
No, it's peterodactyl.
Guys, it's always been peterodactyl.
It's like dodo birds.
You don't know how to, what the fuck they taste like.
They were historical records.
Oh yeah, someone tried to actually me.
Garlic, thank you for the super chat thingy thingy.
Historical records writings indicate that they didn't taste
very good.
But they were eaten to extinction because it was the only
meat around for miles.
Like they would park boats on the island to eat them.
Wait, what?
They would park boats?
There's like other, there's fish.
What were fish then?
Like, what were fish?
No, they described as tough but good.
And like, some hunted dodo is only for the gizzards because
the most delicious part of the bird.
Yeah, see, I told you.
You can't actually mean Wikipedia, which is the best of uh
yeah see there's always people saying dodo's must have
tasted uh see like okay some people say look it's like
preferences some are like oh it wasn't that great but then
others are saying that um they were good
let's see how big were dodo's they were like 40 pounds oh my
god they were like bigger than turkeys
mid 17th century taking straight blue pairs are very
numerous as well as other birds their birds lacked wings
blah blah blah blah uh nevertheless their belly and breast
were of a pleasant flavor see look at that okay nevertheless
their belly and breasts were of a pleasant flavor there you
go there you go guys i told you guys it's all about
preferences some people don't doesn't like beef there some
people don't like beef but then yet they still eat it so as
we'll eat anything that isn't hard tacked that's true that's
so true stream tack education uh to be fair i hate turkey i
don't i don't understand why people like to eat turkey
because i find turkey to be like very dry and uh not i mean
not like and flavorless You have to put like fucking gravy
or something to make it taste like great.
You need to put actual like gravy and and like cranberries
to actually make it like taste like something.
But like I feel like turkey is very dry.
Not dry.
I mean turkey is very flavorless in general.
Yeah I think like turkey is inferior chicken.
It truly is.
I mean they're stupid.
I mean to be very chicken is like like just that's.
stupid but turkeys is like they're it's like turkeys we've
read we domesticated them so hard that like like have you
seen like the the size of a turkey brain size um turkey
brain they're very yeah it's like a pea that's like how tiny
it is it's like the size of a fucking p that's so tiny yeah
it's p size wow turkeys yeah but like i'm talking about like
it's the same thing like of course domesticated turkeys are
are really stupid because you know they've been bred to how
stupid are domesticated domesticated turkeys sorry i had
like a little brain fart where i couldn't even spell
domesticated uh Let's see.
Okay.
Alright, wild turkeys are very intelligent animals.
What the fuck did we do?
Wait.
Apparently, they used to be highly intelligent animals.
What the fuck did we do to the turkey?
Oh my god.
No!
They used to be smart.
Oh my god, it's like me.
I used to be smart.
And then I started streaming.
I used to have...
Like, I used to have a professor that, like, really liked me
and said I was really smart.
And then I don't know what happened.
I just started streaming.
I don't...
I did higher education.
We bread and buttered and art players is every good.
Alright.
Oh!
Alright, we're just waiting.
We're just waiting for the serve at the moment.
We're just waiting.
The day Doki's brain shrunk three sizes.
So true.
whoa sorry i don't know if my chrome wait is my chrome oh
good my chrome is not on okay thank god you guys didn't hear
it let me refresh and see the servers back up i know i did
say like i told hero to let me know but the server's still
not back up yeah so the reason why they had to restart the
server is because apparently somebody did something that
bugged the whole server So they're trying to figure out,
they couldn't figure out what, who did it?
I guess, I guess they couldn't figure out who, it wasn't me,
because it was happening before I was there, guys.
It wasn't me!
It was happening before me, I'll join.
So, what did I do?
I literally, all I did was, I died three times to gravity,
and then, like, three times to a fucking mosquito.
Like, what did I do?
What did I do?
Anyway.
So they're saying that somebody bugged the server.
And then they've been trying to figure out what it was.
But they couldn't.
So that's why they're resetting the server.
So we're still waiting for it.
We're just waiting.
i think like after the tour after the tour and we i know i
said it before but after the tour and domesticating a dragon
we're gonna call it here because i'm getting a little eepie
just getting a little eepie right now
yeah it's really late um i might push the sandland stream um
a bit later
alarms being checked in my apartment so like i'm gonna see
if like uh i'm gonna see if fire alarms will be checked
before my stream and and then if um if the fire alarm people
doesn't come to check it then i might stream a little i
might push the stream back until uh until uh until like they
check it because they have to come into my pc room i think
it's a little awkward you know i think you know it's like
the xqc thing where i don't know you guys seen the that one
of the infamous xqc clips where uh he was you know streaming
and then the maids came in and like like his maids came in
and was just like judging him like i don't want to be judged
uh
I don't want to be judged live by the fire line people.
Oh, you guys haven't seen it.
It's like, honestly, okay, here.
Let me see.
All right, XQC Mates.
what inspired it's the one that uh inspired the um inspired
the uh the meat canyon video yeah oh it's on now okay all
right they had to back up the server but anyway this is the
xqc video i was talking about so and that's like one of the
reasons why i'm thinking about starting the stream later
because i'm scared
I don't want to be judged
Alright, let's see XQC has mates XQC is a fucking
millionaire You know like those gambling Sponsors he takes
Like from that alone You can get like a million plus Like
Like no shit Like, of course he has me.
Alright, we're loading in.
He can afford it.
He gets, like, 50k viewers every stream.
She was reading what he wrote?
I mean, yeah.
That's gonna mean, like, what the fire alarm guy is gonna
think when I start streaming.
gambling is too lucrative it's not even a leak it's common
knowledge why else would they like fucking take those
sponsors and like willing to oh my god i'm alive you guys
thought i would die all right i'm back wait i'm naked no i
was supposed to be naked okay
you guys said i would die look at me i am alive Where's...
Where's...
Where's Hiro?
Where's my carry?
Oh no.
Oh wait, I have a parasaur?
Saddle?
How the fuck did I get all these things?
Okay, let me eat though.
I'm like so hungry.
Okay, where's...
Oh, okay, they're still loading in.
We can explore a little bit.
Apparently...
You're apparently loading in.
How do I explore?
Oh, guys.
You want to see how strong I am?
Look at this.
That's how strong I am, guys.
88 wood.
Right off the bat.
Alright.
Okay, let's, like, level up some stuff.
Okay, apparently we want movement speed.
And then we want stamina.
HP.
stamina, weight, melee, weight, health.
Okay, there you go.
That should be fine.
So how do I craft?
Oh, see, they're online.
That's me.
I'm real female dokey.
I'm right over here.
Oh, Ditto's.
Oh, yeah, Ditto's in here, too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why am I not an admin?
Where the fuck?
How come Ditto is an admin and I'm not?
wait a minute wait is that mine taming effectiveness wild
wait what does that mean
let's see i wonder where did my what am i wait what is that
is this a what is this
what is this that what is that guys what the fuck is this it
says my taming list but i don't know wait i i knocked down
who did who the fuck is this this is not the dragon because
i never tamed a dragon
oh someone is taming a creature right now oh it's not me
okay oh someone in my tribe is taming it see i see okay but
how would i know where i am hello kiro nachan hello
somebody save me
Somebody save me!
Oh hey, crafting.
Can I craft a gun now?
Craft one.
Do I have a gun?
Where is it?
Oh my god, guys.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's a tour!
Oh!
Okay, it looked like a gun.
I'm lost.
Wait, I'm next to...
Next to building...
Next to castle.
I'm in a hole.
Okay, I'm in the hole.
Is that pickaxe?
Hold and reload.
Multi-tool.
But it looks like a gun!
Look at it!
Oh, it's a mod.
Please don't hurt me.
Hello?
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
Hello!
I'm just...
Leave me alone!
Ah!
There's a bird chasing me!
Oh, no.
Are they...
They're not friend-shaped?
keep moving bird versus okay this guy seems nice you're hot
you should find someplace to cool down i'm literally wearing
a bikini what the fuck do you want from me i have the high
ground hello okay what does my map say i don't know what
that means 80 40 okay is that look i even caught the gun
I'm sad.
I created something useless.
That seems like something I do.
Oh, hello!
Yeah!
It's me!
I'm here!
I was so scared.
I was so scared, Hiro.
to kill me okay i'll take it yeah my hero my hero yeah oh
here it is wait did you guys build this no wait this is the
crazy guy this is the crazy guy wait is he online is he okay
i don't know i think he's loading it wait if we Wait, we
should make a cage on him.
Put a cage around him before he can go crazy.
Oh, you have a beautiful home, sir.
You have.
Hello.
Oh,
my God.
I can actually understand.
oh my god you know
he is he is crazy
you you're not there are three people you're three people
you're doing what you're doing what are those three this one
Hello.
Nice to meet you too.
My English is fine.
Your English is amazing.
It's beautiful.
It is great.
Oh!
what did you do i want to take my this body this books she
died she died yeah yes yes bless me good luck bless bless
like this is kory's by the way his name kory's kory's hello
hello hello
so what are you locked you put it in the cup i'm very hot i
want to drink
i don't have water i'm gonna dehydrate
oh i'm okay
you guys have you guys have water oh my god i can't see
anything Oh my god.
Remember to always hydrate.
Wait, how come I can't see anything now?
I can't see names.
Oh no.
Guys, I can't see anything on my screen.
What happened?
There's no more water.
Did you hide your UI?
Wait, my UI is gone.
Wait, I don't know what that is.
Oh my god, I can't see your name.
Oh, okay, never mind.
It's because I pushed backspace.
I figured it out.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh yeah, do you have water?
Apparently I fixed it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I fixed it.
Yeah.
Oh, I think you have my bottle, right?
Yeah, yeah, I have a canteen, but I don't know where to get
water.
There's already no water in there already?
Okay.
I'm dehydrated.
Yay!
Wait, where's Noachan doing?
Wait, oh wait, can you just throw me into the water and then
I get water from that?
Oh!
Okay, I drink.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh my god!
Oh!
You have more HP!
Pick me up, pick me up, pick me up!
Ah, hit it up!
Hit it up, No!
I'm broken!
Wait, wait, wait, I'm still alive.
I'm still alive.
Okay, and I pooped a little bit.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, it's okay.
My bones are back to normal.
My bones are back there.
It's okay.
It just magically healed.
I pooped from the fear.
If you got slapped by a prehistoric animal, you too would
fucking poop out of fear.
Don't fucking lie.
You'd do it if it was a fucking rhino from like modern
creatures.
I'm alive, I'm alive!
Oh my god, pick me up.
I'm so sick
Where did I die?
No fucking way Where did I die?
You guys were Okay What the Did you bleed?
I need it.
It's the huge X.
There's a huge X.
Where the fuck is the X?
What do you mean a huge X?
Everything went.
Where are you?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I found it.
Guys.
Guys, I found it.
I am at...
I am...
What bed am I in?
What the fuck am I?
I'm...
Oh wait.
I spawned...
At the...
Bide.
Oh my god.
Wait, is this a dinosaur?
Oh my god, it is.
Wait, is this dinosaur meant to...
for spawning?
What the fuck?
Oh, that was what's being tamed.
Bide?
Oh, I don't know.
It's like...
I don't know what the fuck is that.
Oh, it's a strider!
Tech strider.
Strider.
later it's blue and tall and metal oh tall is
it this is where this is where i live no my bikini no wait i
have glasses wait not grindable hello hello oh my god
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I'm being fed by the...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, thank you, thank you.
I'm no more yet.
Oh, I'm waiting.
I'm just waiting hero to see if I can get on a fight every
time every fucking bug Like are you serious?
Every time I get on a fight every time Every insect fucked
me over
We're back We're back.
Every insect has fucked me over.
I had one that killed me several times.
And then another one.
Literally, I got on the fucking insect mount.
And then I died.
My PC died.
I hate me.
All bugs are against me.
I just want my loot back.
I want my...
Please.
don't put me in the cage don't put me in the cage
please don't put me in the cage i i'm scared i'm not i'm
scared i'm gonna be this will still be like oh she crashed
it's time to put doki in the cage okay
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Please don't put me in the cage.
I'm so scared.
I'm scared that he's going to realize I crashed and then it
just locks me up.
It's not looking.
I thought we were friends.
We spoke Cantonese to each other.
Hello?
No!
I don't know!
Oh my god!
Wait!
You're doing it again?
Oh my god!
Wait!
Wait, why are you doing it?
Why are you doing it?
Is it okay?
oh my god oh my god oh my god was with me in the game she
almost put me in the game oh my god that was so scary i
almost got fucking put in that cage oh my god wait are these
in the cage what
That could have been me!
I could have been me!
Oh my god, oh my god, I called it I fucking called, I knew
it, guys I fucking called it, guys I knew she wanted to put
me in the cage I fucking knew it Oh my god, that was so
close She's the collector Holy shit What happened last night
Yeah, I got saved Alright.
I can't see.
Do you know?
Huh?
What?
Oh my god!
You're really...
Help!
Head goes!
Hey, okay, you have to wait.
Wait,
wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
She's crazy!
Hiro!
Save me!
What's that?
Oh my god!
Come here!
No!
Oh,
my god.
Oh, my God.
Hiro!
Save me!
She's crazy!
Help me!
They're crazy!
For me, he- he fucking knocked me out and put me in a cage!
He shot me!
What the fuck?
Hiro!
Let me out, Hiro!
Got it.
I got it so bad.
Hiro, you were right!
Hiro!
oh oh thank you okay how do i get out of the handcuffs oh oh
my god
no i'm not okay
he put me in a cage He's hurting at home.
You're right!
Don't worry, I put some shit in his...
In her home, don't worry.
I put some shit!
My hero.
Wait, where's my...
Do you know where my...
Oh my god, she has so many people in cages, look at this.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Wait, do you know where my body is?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, can you take me?
I want my bikini back.
Wait, what do I have?
Oh, Oh, I have water to dry.
Oh my god, she gave me water.
I have a whip now.
Bed!
You should be...
You gave me a whip.
Can you bring me back to my body?
Hey
Oh, yes, I want what is this?
Oh my god, your blood.
Don't worry.
I'll keep it forever Goodbye, everybody
Bye-bye All right, I want my I want my stuff back.
I want my bikini back The crazy person gave me a whip
Oh she freak I'm not the freaky one She gave me the whip
I can't believe I fucking knew it Yeah the crazy person gave
me the whip And then they like locked me in a cage
She was like she was like yeah, yeah, she was like look at
this and then I and then she pulled a gun and then Knocked
me out and then put me in the cage It was so scary
Was it I don't remember oh wait uh where did i die
wait i have a map okay i can't i think it's here was it here
i don't see like the light what's the birds on here oh i see
it i see it it's here it's here it's like wait oh my god
machin died yeah she's dying now she's trying to get her
pizza food okay Okay, I got my stuff back.
Let me put my...
Let me put my bikini on.
Yay!
Okay, now I'm beautiful.
Alright.
Nice.
Yay!
Where are we going?
I will try and...
Okay.
Alright, we're going to go to Natchan now.
Oh, okay.
It's like new place.
everyone leader yeah oh my god oh my god nothing is loading
in yet
no nato no live for me oh who's that oh man uh okay okay
here Okay.
Okay.
You know, you know a couple of us.
She is a family.
Very cute girl.
Nice.
It's okay.
Yes, yes.
Oh my god, it's okay.
As long as she doesn't put me in the cage, I'm fine.
Wait, Natchan died again.
Thank you, Hiro.
I'm a sigh.
Oh no.
Natchan's still dead.
Am I pooping in the sky?
Where?
Natchan is dying.
Yeah, she's dying non-stop.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Natchan, don't worry!
I'll save you!
Natchan!
My inventory is too heavy!
Where is Natchan?
Where is she?
No, no.
Wait, there is she?
Oh, wait, no.
She's not there.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Ah, he took my suit.
some stuff away i have too much stuff yeah guys i have too
much what the fuck okay we're we have like the same armor a
lot of the same armor not gonna lie okay let's see green is
green is the weak one okay i have a lot of these skins i
don't think we need like 500.
oh my god oh my god
Where is Natchen?
Ah, I can't.
Natchen!
You're alive!
Oh my god.
Natchen, Natchen!
Look, Natchen.
Look what I have.
Look.
Okay,
what do I not need?
I don't know how to need all of this.
Okay, let me drop all of this.
Oh my god, I'm...
Okay, yeah, I have so many, like, duplicates from dying all
the time.
I cannot fit all of this.
Okay, nice.
Now I can jump.
Yay!
I'm really tired, so, like, I'm glad.
Well, I'm not glad that I crashed, but, like, I'm gonna...
I think it's at that time we gotta stop.
I think Arc just does not like me right now.
So I'm gonna call it here.
It was fun, though.
I'm really happy that Hiro and her friends, like, gave me a
tour, and everybody's so nice on the server.
like interacting with people um i hope you guys had a fun
time watching too i hope all you guys had a great time just
watching and being put in a fucking cage i'm gonna call it
here i'm actually really tired now i'm gonna uh do i have
like some work stuff at the answer um so i'll let you guys
know i'm gonna push back the satellite stream right now i'm
gonna change the time for it um so um and if like the fire
inspector person that's supposed to check the fire lines
doesn't by then I might just wait until they they they check
the alarms and then um um and then start the stream uh but
yeah it was really fun I had a great time I'm gonna call it
here my voice is dying um I'm a bit I'm EP now but as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check it up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up bring me head
to bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye you